[Musique]
un beau matin d'automne sur la côte est
algérienne les marins de zemmouri ont dû
se frotter les yeux pour y croire
sur les quais du port au beau milieu des
sardiniers ils ont vu débarquer une
jeune femme avec une vieille casquette
délavé sur la tête
depuis ce jour
fatma doit prouver qu'elle mérite le
surnom que son père lui a donné raïssa
autrement dit la capitaine de pêche
[Musique]
oui
regardez c'est le diplôme que m'a remis
le président bouteflika
à l'époque nous n'avions qu'une toute
petite barque avec mes deux frères et
mon père après ça les gens les
journalistes se sont mis à parler de moi
et c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
célèbre
du coup le ministre de la pêche
d'algérie m'a offert un bateau dr omar
rôle qu'elle vous savez pour moi cette
histoire ce n'est pas tous les jours
facile
un jour quelqu'un du ministère de la
pêche
je crois que c'était un des responsables
pour me dire que le ministre voulait
voir fait mal j'ai répondu à son
invitation à il nous a très bien reçus
c'était grandiose
le ministre nous a beaucoup parlé c'est
ainsi qu'ils ont commencé à se demander
comment encourager les femmes de notre
pays a travaillé dans le domaine de la
pêche après ce rendez vous ils ont
promis de donner un bateau à fatal un
bateau pour fatma en ces temps
difficiles pour cette simple famille de
pêcheurs
la promesse du gouvernement algérien
était comme un don du ciel
[Musique]
dans ma famille on m'a appris à être
fière
je suis toujours sorti en pêche avec mon
père et il ne m'a jamais ni la pression
dans mon quartier il n'y a pas de femmes
dans le monde en mer je suis la seule à
faire ce métier quand je parle de ce que
je fais sur les gens n'en croient pas
leurs oreilles sur la page dont la femme
la mère est un métier très dur
impossible la mer est pleine de ce
crédit elle est à la fois le bien et le
mal d'offres des richesses et parfois
elle te reprends tout il est 5 heures du
matin le ciel mehdi prend la mer malgré
des conditions météo excellente l'humeur
à bord est un peu tendue
[Musique]
à cette époque de l'année la rencontre
des courants chauds et froids brasse le
fond de la mer et faire remonter la vase
les poissons déserte alors les zones de
pêche
il y a peu de chances pour que les
filets de la famille soit plein
je vois les filets vides
remonté comme ça sans poisson je pense à
l'énergie déployée
on se réveille très tôt on brûle du
mazout pour pas grand chose en on
dépense notre argent on fait des
sacrifices et la mer nous en rien en
échange
on ressent une sorte d'amertume
on est fâché déçu ce n'est pas comme
quand on fait une bonne pêche
là on ne ressent pas la fatigue malgré
tout et même si les filets se
déchiraient on sait qu'on a bien
travaillé de toute façon je peux vous
dire que ce n'est pas le 15
le débat tout neuf mais il fallait faire
la jeune fatma pêche avec son père
depuis bien longtemps
aujourd'hui à 21 ans elle sait que
l'expérience la chance et surtout la
ténacité sont autant de qualités qui
font un bon marin
hall
ce bateau de 10 mètres et son équipage
familial sont bien sûr un atout pour
elle dans cet univers difficile de la
pêche
cependant pour fatma il y encore des
moments de découragement et de colère
des sentiments qui entame parfois sa
volonté de devenir un jour un vrai
capitaine de pêche
oui
et quand le poisson n'est pas au
rendez-vous et que les retours de mer
sont rudes
la petite famille trouve un certain
réconfort dans l'enceinte de sa maison
juste à côté du port de beau bien sûr
les quasi servile pas sur les chaises
dont le port sardinier de zemmouri la
tradition veut que les pêcheurs se
rassemblent pour goûter le fruit de leur
virée en mer la présence d'une jeune
femme comme fatma n'étant pas souhaité
par les marins la famille de la rice à
des jeunes donc à part pour ne pas
choquer une communauté encore bien
ancrée dans les traditions ancestrales
en algérie et plus encore dans le
domaine de la pêche
la plupart des hommes considèrent que la
place de la femme est à la maison
qu'elle doit veiller à l'éducation des
enfants est organisé les tâches
domestiques
pas question donc pour une jeune fille
comme fatma d'imaginer un jour faire
partie d'une profession jusqu'ici
réservé aux hommes
d'ailleurs il suffit de se promener sur
les quais et d'écouter les marins que
pensez vous d'une femme qui se rend mer
cette histoire de pêche ça ne regarde
qu'elle moi je vous dis ça me laisse
assez indifférent elle est là pour
travailler et c'est tout tout le monde
travaille maintenant que voulez-vous que
je vous dise aujourd'hui dans tous les
métiers
on trouve les hommes et les femmes dans
tous les métiers le travail est quelque
chose de noble
on n'a pas à se moquer d'elle si vous
avez une fille vous l'avez seriez partir
en mer non personnellement je ne
pourrais pas laisser ma fille travailler
ma mentalité ne me le permet pas mais
peut-être que pour le père de fatal à
chacun ses idées sur la question
[Musique]
sur le bord rares sont ceux qui osent
exprimer ouvertement leur opinion sur la
présence d'une femme capitaine
[Musique]
d'ailleurs le plus grand défi de fatma
n'est pas de commander un petit bateau
de pêche
il s'agit surtout pour elle de se faire
accepter dans un univers masculin très
durs à l'égard de la femme et surtout
envers ceux qui voudraient briser les
coutumes
[Musique]
il
non
ce matin sur les quais de zemmouri pas
une femme à l'horizon le rituel qui se
déroule est une affaire strictement
réservée aux pêcheurs de sardines qui
après des mois d'attentes retrouve enfin
sourire
la vente du poisson argenté est
improvisé à peine le bateau amarré dans
une bousculade bruyante
un homme est pris à partie
apparemment ma s'en sort bien
puisque c'est lui qui fixe le cours du
poisson on lui souffle un prix à
l'oreille et après c'est lui qui décide
ça suit à l'oreille c'est simple il faut
absolument que ça reste secret c'est une
vente aux enchères secrète capitaine sur
un sardinier voilà le rêve de fat marque
cela signifierait qu enfin un équipage
la respecte pour ce qu'elle est ou
plutôt ce qu'elle aimerait être en
marins comme les autres en attendant ce
jour béni
il lui faut poursuivre son combat entre
de départ en mer la jeune femme se rend
à alger
direction le ministère de la pêche
histoire de régler un petit problème
le fait d'avoir bénéficié d'un bateau
gratuitement est une chose posséder une
licence de pêche adéquat on est une
autre surtout lorsqu'il faut affronter
de l'administration bon nous nous
l'avons encouragé au départ avec un
sardinier et voulant lui offrir donc la
possibilité de produire de montrer que
le monde marin n'est pas uniquement un
monde à part pour les les ans il ya des
femmes aussi qu'ils peuvent donc être
présente dans ce monde là mais bon pour
qu'elle puisse sortir en mer il nous
faut bien voir
actuellement elle a un rôle pour un
sardinier mais elle n'a pas les
capacités requises en matière de nombre
d'équipages qui lui permette de sortir
avec un rôle de sardines
décidément fatma de la chance il semble
que sa récente médiatisation ne soit pas
étrangère à la bienveillance que lui
portent les autorités maritimes bientôt
alors à son rôle
autrement dit la licence de pêche adapté
à son bateau où les femmes ont du mal à
faire entendre leurs droits rien de tel
qu'une belle histoire pour faire mentir
ceux qui dénonceraient la condition de
la femme en algérie
de retour à zemmouri il faut rattraper
le temps perdu et vite prendre le large
pour voir si comme l'ont prédit les
pêcheurs du port
le poisson est enfin là après quelques
rapides vérifications d'usagé
comme d'habitude c'est fatma qui prend
la barre
la jeune raïssa met le cap à l'ouest
pour aller poser les filets
et l'opération n'est pas une mince
affaire pour le frère et la soeur
ça va trop vite un fait gaffe tu perds
le rythme et le bon côté attention il
n'est en danger
on lève ta main s'il te plaît tu m'as
gaza ne sert pas tu penses pas que le
liège va dans l'autre sens on essaie de
faire battre aussi pour l'ach impôts le
travail en mer est très pénible pour
fatma elle doit non seulement faire
preuve de vigilance mais en plus se
faire obéir et sur le si elle me dit
c'est une vraie prouesse
vous savez la mersey rondelle se faire
obéir par des pêcheurs qui sont stressés
par le danger de la mer il faut être
patient surtout quand c'est une femme
qui donne les ordres
certains ne l'acceptent pas moi je les
habitués de question qu'il sorte avec
moi je leur ordonne de lancer remonter
les filets de larguer les amarres ils
sont habitués à moi maintenant
par exemple quand on est en train de
lancer les filets il ne faut pas causer
chacun doit rester les yeux rivés sur
son ouvrage
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'heure moi je tenais le côté
liège du filet et à lille où le côté
plus c'est quand on lance le filet en
vitesse
ils risquent de s'en mêler donc il faut
être très attentif aux mouvements du
filet pour pouvoir tout le des mêlées ou
cas où il s'accroche pas ce qu'est une
faute d'être couchée au départ
bien sûr que je suis très fier de ma
fille elle deviendra un jour un grand
patron côtier elle vaut au moins dix
hommes en mer elle a du courage et une
sorte de sixième sens pas trop le
poisson si dieu le veut
elle sera une rice a encore plus
extraordinaire le vieil a marre a repris
le goût de la mer depuis qu'il sait que
sa fille est capable de piloter un
bateau sans elle et surtout son le ciel
mais dit il sait aussi qu'il ne pourrait
plus partir à la pêche
faute d'argent
la capitaine fatma et son équipage vont
être bientôt fixé sur le sort qui les
attend
les bois qui flotte à quelques
encablures de la côte sont celles des
filets de la famille
une fois de plus la passion sera payé
vous
en quelques minutes des dizaines et des
dizaines de poissons blancs s'accumulent
sur le pont daurade rascasse pas josé
calamars viennent remplir les caisses du
ciel mais dit il semble que la vase ce
soit à nouveau déposer au fond et que
les méduses et fui la zone
après trois heures de pêche
fatma fait route vers le port avec une
joie non dissimulée pour une fois les
hommes de zemmouri ne pourront pas se
moquer ils devront se contenter de leur
indifférence quotidienne
[Musique]
mais nous
pour la vente du poisson c'est forcément
un homme de la famille qui se rend sur
les quais al helou le jeune frère de
fatma n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche
quand il s'agit de négocier à la hausse
le prix de sa marche en neige face à des
mareyeurs qui on ne la fait pas à les
loups n'a pas son égal pour ce qui est
du marchandage on dit de lui sur le port
qu'il arrive toujours à ses fins
quelques minutes de discussion une
poignée de main et liasses de dinars le
poisson change de mains la porte et 3000
dinars loose
c'est vraiment la baraka même pour si
peu
tu peux chanter jouer au tam-tam même
pensé si ça pouvait être comme ça tous
les jours
ça passe ça irait premier aujourd'hui
trois millions de bain et au bout d'une
semaine j'arriverai à dix ou quinze
mille dinars
pendant ce temps fatma elle traverse le
port pour se rendre en ville
ses copines elle préfère un chemin plus
long afin d'échapper au regard
inquisiteur d'une poignée de marins
désoeuvrés
sans voile et exerçant un métier d'homme
pour beaucoup fatma semble défier la
société en silence
[Musique]
le salon de coiffure est l'un des rares
endroits où les femmes de zemmouri
peuvent se rencontrer échanger sans peur
d'éventuels reproche
pour fatma la raïs à ce moment de
détente c'est aussi une manière de
rompre avec les habitudes et la solitude
du port ici au moins les femmes ont de
la considération pour elle et son
travail
m
vous n'êtes pas sages en soit volontaire
je ne serai jamais capable de faire ce
qu'elle fait est là une volonté de faire
du courage de la persévérance
et puis ses parents savent qu'ils
peuvent la laisser parmi les loups sans
aucune faute
c'est vrai que notre société ne pardonne
pas elle est trop dur on dénigre la
fille travaille surtout la ville après
jour où est le mal dans la mesure où
elle tient son honneur sa fierté et sa
dignité
la société en fin de compte pliera par
son comportement
fatma montre se caleront et elle force
le respect le petit les théories de koné
pour les femmes d'algérie
fatma est donc un symbole de liberté de
courage au delà de son métier de marin
elle porte aussi l'espoir de toute une
génération de jeunes femmes encore
soumise à une loi dépassée qui veut que
les hommes et les femmes ne vivent pas
sur le même pied d'égalité
et
c'est un jour je suis sortie en mer et
j'ai remonté une ré dans le fil de
l'histoire
et regardons de plus près on pouvait
distinguer une marque qui en fait était
inscrit dieu miséricordieux
j'ai pris ça comme un signe du ciel je
remercie dieu pour cette révélation
survient d'être il est vraiment touchée
de voir cette inscription
depuis je me sens comme protégé c'est
vrai que je n'ai jamais affronté la
tempête de ma vie tartan non mais je
m'en sors toujours je n'ai jamais eu de
problème qui fait perdre à nadine files
de voitures
chaque matin fatma s'accroche à serait
fragile celui d'être reconnu comme une
race à mais elle nous a confié qu'un
jour elle devra sans doute choisir entre
l'amour de la mer et celui de son mari
à moins qu'avec la baraka elle ne garde
les deux
où